よろしくお願いします
では始まります 八十八番目
エヴ
ァンメースタッンエカンサマヤンバガワーサーワッティヤンヴィーリティジェータヴァネーアナータピンディカッサヤーラーメーアタコーアーヤスマーアナンドープッ
バンナサマヤンニワーセットワパッタチーヴァラマーダヤーサーワッティンピンダーヤパーヴィティサーウィッティヤンサーワッティヤンピンダーヤパリトワパッチャ
パッタンピンダパータパティカントーレーナプッバーラーモーミガーラマートーパーシャーゴーテーヌパサンカミーディワーヴィハラーヴィハーラーヤーテーナコーパナ
サマエーナラージャパセーナディコーセローエーカプンダリーカンナーガンアヴィルーヒトワサーワッティヤーニーヤーティディワディワッサアッダサーコーラージャ
パセーナディコーセローアーヤスマンタンナナンダンドーラトーアガッチャントァンディッスワーナシリワッダンマハーマッタンアマンテーシアーヤスマニノーエーソサ
ッマシリワッダヤーナンドーティエワンマハーラージャアーヤスマエーソアーナンドーテ
ィア
タコーコーラージャパセーナディコーセローアンニャタランプリサンアマンテーヒアマンテーシエーヒトワンアンブホプリサレーナアーヤスマーアーナンドーテーヌパ
サンカマーパサンカミトワマナヴァチャネーナアーヤスマトーアーナンダッサパーデーシラサヴァンダヒラージャバンテーパセーナディコーセローアーヤスマトーアー
ナンダッサパーデーシラサヴァンダティイティエワンチャヴァデーヒサチェーキラトゥンメーアーヤスマトーアーナンダッサエーナキンチアッチャーイカンカラニヤンア
ーガメーチュキラバンテーアーヤスマーアナンドームフッタンアヌカンタンウパーダーヤーティ
止まるとこだね ではまあそこら辺ストーリーですからね
そのまま読んでみたっても
日本語で読んでみたっても
あまり難しいところはないと思います
それもお釈迦様がこのサーワッティ町でジェータワナというお寺で住んでいた時の話なんです
アタコ その時アーヤスマーアーナンド
このアーナンダソンジャ
日本語でこのアナンソンジャでしたっけ
アナンソンジャというこのアーナンダソンジャですね
プッバンナサマヤンっていうのは
午前中ニワーセットワ
衣を着て パッタチーヴァラマーダヤー
鉢と衣を持ってサーワッティンピンダーヤパーヴィティ
斎場へ托鉢に出かけましたと
そこでこのニワーセットワっていうのは衣を着ること
巻くことなんですね またパッタチーヴァラマーダヤー
鉢と衣を持ってっていう
またあるんですね それはどういう意味かというと
これ今私はその二つ衣を着ていますけど
これは着る部分ですよ
腰巻きと上の方が もう一つ衣があるんです
それはあまり着ないで持っていくんです
だから三枚でワンセットなんですね
だから戒律はいつでもこの三枚も自分のところに持っておかないといけないっていうことです
私は全然三枚目を持ってないんですね
ですから この戒律の儀式とかある場合は
みんな必ず三枚目持っておいておくんですね
それは例えばこれ汚れたとかなんとかなったら
それに着替えることもできるし
あるいは 三枚目の衣ね
例えば外れたらすごく寒くなったりしますね
その場合はそれを巻いたりする
あるいはどこかに座る時でも
時々それはもう座布団代わりに使ったりとかね
まあいろいろあったんです
三枚目と二枚目は形は一緒ですか
形は一緒ですけど 厚さが二重構造ですね
それは 昔は衣っていうのはね
なかなか手に入らないしね
で 大変高価ってしょうしね
だからあっちこっちでこの捨てた布切れとかね
拾って拾って抜いて抜いて抜いて作るもんですよ
ですから一つ作ったら
もらったら それはもうボロボロになるまで着るんですね
ですから 自分の持ち物として三枚
三柄と鉢と神輿と 座る時は何か拭いて座るんです
いつでも それも自分の個人用なものをいつでも持っているんです
そういうものは一人の人の持ち物
それはどこへ行っても持っていく
だから昔お寺 どんなお寺でも
いくらお坊さんが来ても別に困ることはないんです
自分自分の持ち物を全部持っているんだから
ただここら辺 場所さえあれば
そこら辺 寝たければ衣を二枚も敷いて
そこで横になって寝るとかね
ご飯食べたければ自分の鉢でご飯食べると
どこかに座る場合は自分で敷くものは持ってますから
それ敷いてそれで座るということだから
誰にでも迷惑をかけないということでしたけどね
そこで托鉢に出かけましたと
托鉢終わってパッチャーバッタンというのはご飯食べてからイェーナプッバーラーモミガーラマートパーサード他のお寺に行きたかったんですね
でお釈迦様がジェートワナというお寺に泊まっていましたし
この西側にジェートワナという寺院とプッバーラーマという寺院二つあったんです
この二つもものすごいもうものすごいバカでかい大きいところでしたからね
このジェートワナラーマの遺跡は今もありますよ
プッバーラーマもあると思います
あると思います ちょっと思い出せませんだけどね
すごいところですよ ものすごい大きいんです
お釈迦様が住んでいた部屋もね
その跡もあるし 大きいといえばかなりもう何千人もね
集めるところでしたからね
毎日毎日 そこでこのジェートワナラーマはアナータピンディカコジが作ってあげたもので
このプッバーラーマっていうのは
ある女性が作って布施したものなんですね
ヴィサーカー夫人というヴィサーカー夫人が寄付したものですね
彼女もすごい資産家で
ですから やっぱりいつでも女性と男性
ちゃんと五分五分にバランスを整えているんです
だからお釈迦様がジェートワナラーマには長い間もう長い回数が多いんですけど
次に回数多いのはこのプッバーラーマというところなんですね
それでミガーラマートっていうのはこのヴィサーカー夫人の名前なんです
名前はヴィサーカーですけど
ミガーラマートという名前で有名になっちゃったんです
ミガーラというのは旦那の名前なんです
で 旦那が邪教の人で かなりいい加減でいて
ヴィサーカー夫人が結婚お嫁に行く前にも預流果に悟っていた人で
ですごい頭がいいんですね
で まあそれであの彼女がこのジャイナ教のお坊さんたちにあまりこの礼をするとこもしないし
このお布施あげようともしない
そこで家の人々は これはこのもうお嫁さんが頑固ではないかと
家のしきたりぐらい守ったらどうですかということで
すごい大騒ぎになっちゃったんですね
で 彼女はいい そんなことはないんですよと
あなた呼んでないだけですよと
言ったらもうじゃあだったら今度はね
自分のお坊さんたちが来るんだから
ちゃんと家のね もう何と言いますか
奥さんとして行って挨拶しなさいと言ったら
まあとにかくすごいもう金持ちの人々だから
まあ普通の人々をお世話全部しているし
まあかなりの派手にファッションに流行りますからね
もうすごいおしゃれしていた人みたいです
ものすごい美しい方で
だから彼女は自分のアクセサリーあちこちに全部つけて
堂々と家の主人と主人ではなくてね
奥さん通してこの建物に入りました
入ったところでジャイナ教の人々なんですね
みんなお坊さんたちが服着ないんですね
みんなたくさん座ってるんで
男たちが 出家の修行 みんな裸ですね
それを見た途端 彼女がものすごくびっくりしちゃって
もうものすごい声出して逃げちゃったんです
なんて恥知らない人々の前に私をもう連れてくるんですか
そこでこの恥知らな人々の前に連れてくるということで言っちゃったら
もうジャイナの人々もものすごいプライド崩れちゃって
旦那さんも 何の女の人と結婚したんでしょうかと
で困って でもしょうがないんですね
前もって言ってなかったしね
そこで喧嘩になっちゃって
夫婦喧嘩に 夫婦に喧嘩になったらもう彼女はね
もうあなたの家は他の宗教の家だから
私は黙っていたんだけど
私も私の宗教ありますよと
私の仏教はそういう教えだよと
我々のお坊さんたちっていうのはもっと行儀がいいんだと
人の前に体は見せませんと
ものすごい恥を知ってるんだと
言葉をものすごく惜しんで喋るんだよと
あっちこちぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ見て歩くもの
歩くこともしませんと
一歩一歩歩くときでも
すごく丁寧に気づいて歩いてるんだと
ご飯食べる時はかすかな音も立てませんよと
あっちこっちご飯散らかしたりすることもしませんよと
やってもお釈迦様やら比丘たちの戒律の生活
生き方とか 全部説明してあげたんですね
ですから あなたも一度見てみたらどうですかと
言ったら まあいいや あんたそんなに言うんだったらね
いいでしょうと言って
じゃあお坊さん お釈迦様呼びましょうということで
お坊さん お釈迦様にも比丘たちと一緒に来るように呼んだんですね
呼んだらジャイナの方がね
これまずいことになりましたと
お釈迦様っていうのはものすごい論理的だから
もう一回話しちゃって
お釈迦様お話したらもう仏教徒になっちゃうでしょうに
それもう決まってるんですね
彼らにとってはもう大変なもう豊かな信者さんでしたしね
それなくなるのはね 本当にかわいそうでしょうと
ですから これやめなさい
やめなさいとはね これ大変危険なことをあんたがやってるんだと
ブッダっていうのは この何といいますか
おまじない？呪術師でしょうし
だからその呪術にはもう誰でも引っかかっちゃいますよと
引っかからない人は一人も人間の中でいないんだと
それでもう大変なことになりますと言ったら
まあそれでも断れないし
偉い人がね 約束したものはね
あれをやめますたってこと言えませんし
それでまあだったらもう一応顔ぐらい合わせないようにしなさいと
そういうことで まあそれいつでもある話でね
まあそれでも自分が出ないで
夫人だけ出て まあお釈迦様のお世話をすると
旦那さんが顔を合わせない
で 後ろにカーテンの後ろにもう隠れている
隠れてるところでウィサーカさんに
お釈迦様がもう小さい時からもう仲良しでしたからね
子供頃からの 彼女にいろいろ話をすると
この人が話を聞いていて驚いちゃって
それでお釈迦様に礼をするんですね
来て お釈迦様側にもまあそれなりに対して説法して終わったら
まあそれっきり仏教徒になるんですね
で それでこんなに素晴らしい教えに導いたのはあなたですからと言って
あなた私の奥さんよりももう道を案内した母親だよと
言って 彼女にもう母親みたいな感じで尊敬するようになっちゃったんです
それからミガーラマートというのはあだ名がついてしまったんですね
ですからミガーラマートといえばもうウィサーカという人になるんです
アーナンダ尊者がこのブッバラマというこの東寺院ですね
日本訳は あのミガー...え？ 東院
昼はそのお寺にいますよということで行ったんですね
その時コーサラ王様がこのエーカプンダリーカナーガンというのは象の名前でしょうかね
和訳の方には名前 象の名前だそうです
うん エーカプンダリーカ
象に おそらく名前でしょうね
注釈書には由来が書いてあるみたいですけど
そうですか  その像のろっ骨の上にタラジの果ほどの白い箇所があった
それゆえに彼にエーカプンダリーカという名がつけられたと
ターラ・パレ・マッタン
パンダラッターナン・アッティ
ああ これいわゆる鼓舞ですね
ね で ロコスの上っていうのは
象の場合はここら辺ですから
まあちょっとパーラパラっていうのはまあこれぐらいの大きさのものとか
これぐらいかな ただ手で持てるぐらいの
けどヤシの一種類ですけどね
まあちょっとしたコブがあったんですね
それをまあその象の触角で
それでもプンダリーカっていうのは初の花なんですよ
エーカっていうのは一つというね
まあ単なる名前だと思います
この注釈書のいわれはね
あんまり その象に乗って出かけちゃ
昼出かけたんですね 用事があって
で 王様が象の上から遠くお坊さんを見たところで
おそらくはアナンダ尊者ではないかと確認して
自分のそばにいた大臣
大臣の名前はシリワンダー
大臣にあれアナンダ尊者ではないかと聞くんですね
そこで大臣もちょっと見て
いややっぱりアナンダ尊者ですよと
言ったらもう一人の家来の人に命令するんですね
アンブホープリセン まああんたが行ってアナンダ尊者に王様が礼をするんだって礼しなさいと
礼をしてアナンダ尊者に何か特別な用事がなければ
ちょっと待っていただけませんかと
という話 その人も行ってそのことを報告する
そこからこの百十三ページのちょっと下ですね
アビワーセシコアヤスマアナンドトゥンヒバーウェーナ
アナンダ尊者が黙ってOKしたんですね
アッカコーラージャパセナジーコーセロコーセロヤーワティカーナアガッサホーミーナーゲーナガントワーナーガーパッチョーローヒット
ワーパッティコーバエーナーヤスマアナンドテーヌプサンカミー
王様がアナンダ尊者がいるところに象に乗ってそのまま行って
それから降りてそばには歩いていったんですね
ウプサンカミットワーアナンダンアビワーデットワーエーカマンタンアッターセーカマンタンティトーコーラージャパセナジーコーセロアヤスマンタンアナンダンイータドウォーチャ
で 尊者に礼をしてこう言います
サチバンテーヤーヤスマトワーアナンダッサーナキンチアッチャーイカンカラニーヤンサードゥバンテーヤーヤスマアナンドーイエーナアチラワティアナディアティー
ランテーヌプサンカマトゥアヌカンパンウパーダーヤーティ
王様がアナンダ尊者とちょっとお話をしたいんですね
ですから もし尊者にキンチアッチャーイカンカラニーヤン
ものすごい大事な何か用事がないならば
このアチラワティという川のところに行っていただけませんかと
そこら辺がチローティっていう川が流れていましたし
その川の方に行っていただいて
そこら辺はちょっとお話しできる場所でしょうね
それでアナンダ尊者は川のところに行って
ある木の下で座ります
で また王様が象に乗って
またその川のところに行って
また降りて アーナンダ尊者がいるところに行くんですね
言って ［外国語］やっぱりその場合も同じくもう象にあの置いてるシートやらね
それはまあ取ってきて
こちらに座ってくださいと
そしたらアナンダ尊者はそれを断るんですね
で 王様は自分の席に座ったら
これから質問が出てきます
一番下の方で ［外国語］このように言いました
［外国語］で お釈迦様の行為のことを聞くんですね
アーナンダ尊者よ 他の人々は
沙門や婆羅門たちによって非難されるような身の行いをされることがありうるのでしょうか
そういう質問です だから体の行為のことでね
何かみんなに非難されることでも
どんな人間でも時々いろいろこともやってますから
これはいけませんよと
言われる何かそういう行為はありましたと
言ったら ［外国語］お釈迦様はそういうことはしませんと
［外国語］次に［外国語］じゃあ言葉でも時々離しますかと
非難されるような言葉
それはそんな言葉もそういう喋りません
それでマノーサマチャーラン
いろいろ考え方を持ってますかと
他の沙門や婆羅門たちに非難されるような考え方を持ってますかと
言ったら いえ そういう考え方は持ってないんだよと
それで王様が質問が終わってしまっちゃったんです
質問の仕方がちょっとまあどうかなったかもしれません
とにかくそれで彼がこう言うんですね
［外国語］これは不思議ですよと
［外国語］私は質問して
もうそれは満足いけるように質問することは
本人が満足していけないんですね
満足いけるような質問をすることはできなかったんですけど
［外国語］アナンダ尊者はもう二度質問できないように
もう答えてしまっちゃったんだと
そこで王様が自分の本音を言うんですね
［外国語］それでアナンダ尊者に言うんです
［外国語］もう頭の悪い人々
アウヤッターっていうのは知識のない勉強していない人々がアナノウィッチャ
根拠もない 証拠も出せないという意味なんですね
アパリヨーガーヘットワーっていうのは
この両側なくて言いたい放題という
パレーサン 他人のワンナン
褒めること 褒める褒め言葉かアワンナン
非難の言葉とかもう喋るんだと
人を褒める時でも別に証拠でもどうでもいいんですけど
言いたい放題褒めると
非難する時でも証拠を出すことも何もなく
もう言いたい放題言いますと
それはどのように日本訳になってますか
尊者よ  311ページの中ほどです
尊者よ 不聡明な武者たちはよく知らず
よく確かめず 他の者たちを称賛し
あるいは非難します  よく知らず
よく確かめずというですね
よく知らずってのはパーリ語でこのアナノウィッチャという言葉で
アナノウィッチャっていうのはこのしっかりと情報を調べて
この確認することですね
アパリヨーガーレタというのは両方のことなんですね
やっぱりもう言うは言うは言うはもう切りがなく喋るというね
そういうことなんです
それで王様がそんなやり方は気に入らないんだと
マヤンタンサーラとパッチャガッチャーナ
私はその話には意味のあると
何もこの何て言いますか
意味があると思わないんだと
サーラっていうのはエサンスですね
ですから 何も根拠 意味があると私は思いませんと
真実として認めることがありません
かなり王様もしっかりしていますけど
その点では ただ 世の中の噂だけはそのままでは認めないということなんです
イエーテコーテバンテパンディタヴァッターメーダーヴィノ
パンディタっていうのは頭の良い人々
賢者ということで ヴァッターってのはよく勉強している人々で
メーダーヴィンっていうのは智慧の鋭いという同じ意味ですけど
全部 アノビッチャ よく調べて確かめて
パリヨーガーヒタ ちゃんと量知って
これぐらい褒めればいいというのを知って
パレーサンワンナンヴァアワンナンヴァバーヒティ
他人を褒める時でも批判する時でも
ちゃんと量を知って喋るんだと
それまで確かめて情報があって
タンマヤンサーラとパッチャガッチャーナ
そういうのは私は意味があると
真実だと思いますよと
と自分の本に言うんですよ
ですから 実際はこの王様が困ってるんですよ
この同じ会場でいろんな宗教があるでしょうに
お互いにものすごく非難し合ったり
もう喧嘩してたりするんですね
だから仏教に対してジャイナ教はかなり攻撃していましたし
バラモン教も結構機嫌が良かったわけじゃないんですね
でもバラモン教にとっては批判するときは批判するんだけど
半分以上のバラモンたちは仏教は信じているし
だからややこしかったんだけどね
でもお釈迦様が非難したければ
もう堂々と非難したりもする
それで王様ってのは国王だから
もうみんなの王でしょうに
みんなもう王のところにも来る
だから王様としてはもう一つの宗教ばっかりやるわけにはいきませんし
他の宗教のこともね ちゃんとそれなりに面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないし
だから王様としては困るんですよと
誰かが来てね さんざん他の宗教の悪口言って
王様の宗教とんでもないことだからちゃんと気をつけたんですよ
でいたっても証拠もないし
まだ言いたい放題ことを言ってるだけであって
なんかこの人言ってるの嘘ではないかというのを王様が自分で決めてしまった
それでちゃんと証拠を出して
こういうこういうわけで
こういうこういうことになりましたと言ったら
あ なるほど なんかあるみたいって
で それなりの対応を取れますからね
王様は政治家として自分のちょっとしたトラブルがあるんですね
それでちょっと仏教からそれは知りたがっていたんですね
いわゆるこれは単なる悩みがある
アーナンダ尊者にちょっと話やってみたケースなんですね
そこで彼が自分勝手にこの
あの 辛苦の行為に対して
他人に批判される行為に対して
あなたはお釈迦様はそんなことをしますかと
それだけ聞いたんですね
お釈迦様はそういうくだらない王様が困るようなことを言ってますかと
そんなこと言ってないんだよと言ったところで
また王様がやっぱりさすがこの
この他人に非難されることっていうのは何なのかとちゃんと教えてもらうんですね
そこで質問を 次の質問はカタモパナバンテアーナンダカーヤサマーチャーローオーパアランボウサマネーヒブラームネーヒヴィンニョーヒ
沙門たち バラモンたち
賢者たちに非難される体の行為は何でしょうかと言ったら
ヨーコーマハラージカーヤサマーチャーローアクセロー
まあ不善な行為は非難されますよと
したら王様がカタモパナバンテカーヤサマーチャーローアクセロー
不善な行為って何ですかと
すると それはサーワッジョ
間違ってる行為だよと
そこで間違ってる行為って何でしょうかと
言ったらサウヴィアパッジョ
まあ少々言葉の遊びもあるかもしれませんけど
サーワッジョサウヴィアパッジョと
サウヴィアパッジョっていうのはやっぱり
まあ怒りに まあ怒り 憎しみに基づいた行為
怒りですね そこで害意の怒りの
まあ行為って何でしょうかと言えば
ヨーコーマハラージドゥッカヴィパーク
まあ苦しい結果になるものだと
それで苦しい結果になる行為は何でしょうかと言ったら
それでやっと説明するんですね
ヨーコーマハラージカーヤサマーチャーローアッタヴィーアーバーダーヤティサンワッタティパラヴィーアーバーダーヤティサンワッタティウバヤヴィーアーバーダーヤティサンワッタティ
タッサアクセラーダンマアビワッダンティクセラーダンマパリハヤンティエーヴァルーポーコーマハラージカーヤサマーチャーローオーパアランボウサマネーヒブラームネーヒヴィンニョーヒ
まあこれでこの経典言いたがっているところはそれだけでは終了しますけどね
そこでこの体でする行為はアッタヴィーアーバーダーヤティサンワッタティ
自分の破壊になる行為
ヴィーアーバーダーっていうのは自分の破滅
破壊 堕落ですよ だから自分のことを破滅になる
堕落になる行為はもう悪いと
それからパラヴィーアーバーダーヤ
他人の破滅に堕落になる行為も良くないんだよと
それからウバヤヴィーアーバーダーヤ
両方の堕落になる行為も悪いんだよと
その行為はもう悪い行為だと
それは悪い苦しみの結果が作る作るんだと
それは仏教の道徳論の基本なんですね
で 私たちはまあ何かやりたくなったら
このやりたいことが本当にいいことか悪いことかとまずわからないでしょうね
ただやりたいだけで 何か買い物したかったら買いたい
買いたい それだけで それはいいことか悪いことか自分でわからないんですね
だから大体人間みんなやってからあれやらなかった方がよかったなと後で後悔するのは普通の人間の生き方なんですね
まず人に怒鳴っちゃう
怒鳴ってからやっぱり怒鳴らなかった方がよかったなとかね
あんなこと言わなかった方が
もう後の祭りですからね
だからどんな人でも一旦罪を犯してからこれが罪でしたと気がつくんですよ
でももうもう罪を犯してるんですよ
そのところが気をつけてほしいというところ
だから犯す前に 行為を行う前にチェックしなきゃいけないんですね
それが私たち知らないので
その方法が まだやってもないのに
どうやってわかるんでしょうかと
というのは普通の常識なんですね
それでお釈迦様が基準を決めてるんですね
行為っていうのは 自分の幸せになるものでなきゃいけません
まず ですから 自分に対しては何かメリットがないとやる意味がないんですよ
ですから やる前に私に何かメリットがあるかと
調べる じゃあそれでやっぱりメリットがあると
でもそれやっていいんですかね
自分にはメリットがあるんだからといって
それはいいわけじゃないんですよ
自分だけにはいくらメリットがあっても
それは善行為だと決めるのはできないんですよ
だから 他人にどういう結果があるかと調べないと
だから自分の行動が 例えばここら辺でね
ありったけの拡声器いっぱい使ってね
ものすごいバカでかい声でね
カラオケ歌っても 本人が楽しいかもしれませんよ
周りにだってどうでしょうかとかね
まあ例えば自分の家のゴミやらね
まあ畑のこともいいんですけどね
全部やって ゴミの捨てるものは全部隣にポーンと捨てちゃうと
自分だとすっごく楽なんです
だからといって それは善行為にはなりません
いえ これ私にとっては大変楽でメリットがあるんだと
と言っても それはもう不善行為なんです
なぜならば 他人に対しては迷惑だからなんですね
じゃあ他人に迷惑がなければいいっていうわけでもないんです
例えば 他人のためにいろいろことをやってあげたところで
自分がすごくデメリットになると
それまたもう良くないしね
ですから やっぱり善行為っていうのは
自分にも他人にもメリットがあるということなんですね
私はこれはもうちょっと伸ばして説明しますけど
私たちはこの家族でグループで生活しているんだからね
自分だけ良ければいいわけじゃないんですよ
自分やりたいことはね
やっぱり家族に迷惑があると
それはやってはいけないんだよ
たとえ自分にとって楽しい行為であろうとも
家族に迷惑だったら それはやめた方がいいんですね
それで自分とかそこにはいいことなんですけど
普通に他の人々に 社会に
世界に迷惑だったら それもやめた方がいいんですよ
だから仏教の道徳 善行為っていうのは
全ての生命に幸福になる行為なんです
だから仏教的で簡単に言えば
我々は好き勝手に自然破壊してるでしょ
あれは不善行為なんですね
悪行なんですよ 罪なんです
で 自分にお金あるんだからといって
もう車何台も好き勝手に使ったりして
もう大量にもう何て言いますか
二酸化炭素を出したりとかね
それでも自分がもう地球を汚染しているんですね
余分に それもやっぱり悪行為なんですよ
で いろんな工場やらいろんなところで
とにかく自然環境も壊してでも儲かることしか考えない
例えば日本のいろんな工場とかね
一生懸命いろんなもの作って売って売って売って
それで日本だけは儲かるかもしれません
でもそれで地球が破壊してたならば
やっぱりそれは悪行為なんですね
ですから 国のスケールで見ても
いろんな外国でも中国でもいろんなものをやってるでしょうね
それで地球破壊になってるんですね
それでみんなもう知らんふりをするんですね
関係ないとか まああの冷倉庫に使うガス昔使ってた
あれなんていうの？フロンガス
それは使ってはいけませんということになったら
あるニュースで見たんだけど
ドライクリーニング屋さんが 一千万円を借金して新しい機械を買ったみたいですね
で その機械でこの大計量するのはフローリンジャーやつをいっぱい使うんですね
ものすごい そこで彼がものすごく怒って
そんなことを決めたら困りますよと
もう怒って もう散々もう批判するんですね
でもあれは悪行為なんです
自分が発見したんだからといって
地球破壊しなさいと その人に特別権利を与えるわけにはいきませんでしょうしね
ですから 善行為っていうのは
そうやってすべての人々の幸福を作るやり方なんですね
そこら辺は仏教の経典でははっきりしていますから
そこら辺単純で書いているんです
それから悪いことをすると
どんどんアクサラダンマアビワッダンティ
どんどん自分の心の悪いことは増えていく
クサラダンマパリハヤンティ
善良いことが減っていく
そういうことが悪行為で悪い行為だよと説明しているんです
そこでこの体の行為 言葉の行為
それから考えること 考えることも同じなんですね
私は一人で考えているんだから
あんた方に関係ないんだよと
と思ってはいけません
一人で悪いことを考えてはいけないんですね
だからみんなこの特に日本にあります
特に日本にその現象はありますよ
一人で自分の部屋でコンピューターいじったり
いろいろメール送ったりして
自分だけの世界でくだらないことを考えたりして
突然外に出て行って誰かを殺しちゃうんですね
いろんな変な漫画ばっかり見たりとかね
あれは考え方の問題なんですね
みんなまあ一人でやっていることだからいいんじゃないかと
でもいいわけじゃないんです
だからやっぱり悪いことを一人で考えてもいけないんですね
だから考えるときでも
人類のために 生命のために
また慈しみの考え方とか
一人でいるときでも考えなくちゃいけない
それも悪行為として仏教で思っているんですね
仏教では考える行為の罪が重いんです
体でやることよりも その経典も一つあります
どんな罪が重いんですかと
言葉をしゃべること 体でやんのか
人を殺したりすること
あるいは頭で悪いことを考えること
言ったらお釈迦様ははっきり言って頭でやること
罪が重いんですよと 体でやることよりも
仏教の順番は頭で考えることが一番罪が重い
それより言葉の方が罪が弱い
体の場合もっと弱いと
我々の考え方を見れば
やっぱり実際にやる方がもっと重いんじゃないかと
人を殺したいなと思ったこと
もう思っただけだからいいんじゃないかと私たちは思いますけど
仏教はそれは逆だと なぜかというと
体の行為っていうのは必ずリミットがあります
私に人を殺したくたって
もう何人殺せられることね
例えばみんな殺そうと思ってもできないでしょうね
せいぜい一人二人でもうこちら捕まりましたからね
リミットがあるんですよ
そこで医者がいる 医者が腹が立って漫画見て
もう人を殺したくなる
平気でもっとたくさん殺されるでしょうに
何のことなく まあそういうケースもあったでしょうに
来る来る人が死んでしまっちゃうと
病院に誰か若者がね まあ腹が立っても人が死ぬ薬をね
いただい-- やっぱり頭であまり考えない
あまり能力ない私だったらもうせいぜい一人ぐらいでしょうしね
それがもうちょっと頭勉強してる医者だったらもう人でも平気で
イギリスにいたんですね
人以上殺す人かな 今捕まったんだけどもね
その人いまだに認めない
それはもう人殺しじゃないんだと
とにかく彼がこのホームドクターでいろんなところにホームドクターとして行くんですね
彼がこの電話かけてもらって行ったならば
行って帰るとその人が死ぬんですね
いつでも 死んだのはみんな老人たちなんですけど
で見たら面倒くさい もうまあどうせ老人だからといって注射打って帰っちゃう
それがもうこの人わざわざと殺しているということはバレなかったんですね
大体医者だからちゃんと知ってますよ
ただ自然に審査心臓が停止して死ぬ
なんとか薬ありますね
だからまあどうにもならない
それでもやっとおかしくなっちゃって
この人が診察室に行ったら
ちょうどその時間に合わせて同じ時間で人が死ぬ
あの家でもこうで この家でもこうで
それでたくさんケース調べたところでおかしいということで人捕まっちゃったんですけどね
だからやっぱり頭の方がね
危険ですよ それで私にはこの体で人一人ぐらい殺せますけど
言葉で悪口を言うならばいくらでも言えるでしょうに
感じなく ですから 言葉の方も罪の量がすごい多いんです
言葉でもって人を一生悩ますこともできるでしょうにね
すごい力持ってますよ
殺すよりは一生苦しめてやるぞと思っちゃえば
もう簡単にできるでしょうに
ですから 言葉の罪はもっと強いんですね
それよりももう頭で考える方が一番危ないと
ですから 頭では勝手に悪いことを考えていけないというのは
まあその方が完璧に頭で悪いこと考えないと
口でも悪いこと言えないでしょうに
体でも悪いことできないでしょうに
で 完璧になるんですね
そこであの百十五ページの三番目の段落
キン
ヌコ・バンテ・アーナンダ・ソー・バガヴァー・サッベー・サンガー・アクサラナン・ダンマナン・サハーナン・ワンネーティーティー・サッバー・クサラ・ダンマ・
ダンマ・パヒーノー・コー・マーラージャ・タターガトー・クサラ・ダンマ・サマンナーガトーティー
そこで次の質問は で 釈尊が全ての悪行為
をやめなさいとおっしゃってるんでしょうか？いわゆるお釈迦様が全ての悪行為のやめることを褒めてますか？という直訳なんですね
それでアナンダ尊者の答えはサッバー・アクサラ・ダンマ・パヒーノー・コー・マーラージャ・タターガトー
如来は全ての不善行為をから離れているんだと
それからクサラ・ダンマ・サマンナーガトー
一切の善に善になってるんだと
いわゆる完全善者になってるんですね
ですから まあ訳せば お釈迦様はいかなる悪いことでも認めないという
まあそこはこの大事なことで
この まあいろいろ他の宗教で見ると
このいろんな条件付きで悪いことを認めるんですね
例えばユダヤ教だったらこのイスラム教も同じですけど
この目には目という考え方を持ってますね
いわゆる殴ったら殴り返すのが正しいと
まあ殺したら自分のイスラム教だったら自分の息子殺したら殺した人の息子も殺しちゃえばいいと
そういうこの目には目という論理あるんですね
で イエス様はその間違いと言って
まあそれは否定しましたけどもね
ユダヤ教ではまあその通りなんですね
でもイエス様の教えはもう純粋に残ってはないんですからわかりませんだけど
そこでクリスト教になってくると
もうあっちこっちあっちこっちで
やっぱりどこがどうかで肯定してるんですね
まあもう誰かまあけなすこと
まあ殴ること まあそれはまあいろいろ条件付きでいいと
[咳]だから仏教の立場は悪いことは条件付きであろうが何であろうが
悪いことっていうのは純粋に悪いんだと
例えば 私に誰かがものすごい侮辱するとしますね
もう根拠もないことで
もう散々 それでそれほど怒って私を侮辱するんだったら
一言葉言い返してもいいんじゃないかと
で 私が一言葉でその人を侮辱すると
それも悪いんです たとえ裁判で私が勝つかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりかすかにでも悪いことをするなよと
もっと厳密に言えば 私を殺そうとする
その時私はその人を殴って怪我したと
でも自分も人を怪我したという罪を犯してるんです
人に怪我させたという
ですから こうやって完全に悪いことをやめなさいと
それしか道がないんですよ
例えばセルフディフェンスという自己防衛のために殺すのは犯罪ではないとか何とかあっちゃうと
それでも人間はガタガタ状態になっちゃうんですね
道徳っていうのは だからセルフディフェンスという概念さえも殺してもいいということになっているんだから
だから殺される恐れが出てくるんですね
例えばセルフディフェンスでピストルを持ってもいいということになるでしょうに
それは自分殺されかけたら撃つために持っているんですよ
そこまでいいんですよ
そこで誰かと喋っている途中でもう喧嘩になる
自分が侮辱されたことになる
なったら感情的な色取ってもう殺すことになるでしょうに
だからセルフディフェンス概念っていうのは本当に危険な概念なんです
だからセルフディフェンスとしてもピストルを持ってはいけないということになったならば
その人はピストルを持ってはいけない
法律違反だから そこで侮辱されても
もう相手を殺さずに済むんでしょうに
ですから かすかにでも悪いことに隙間
穴を置いておいてはいけないんですね
心には そこは仏教の道徳の立場なんです
そこでその同じことの反対のとこをずっと言ってますね
カッタモウパナバンテヤーナンダカーサマチャーローアノパーランボウサマネーヒブラフマネーヒビンニューヒー
非難されない行為は何でしょうかと言ったら
善行為だよと 善行為って何でしょうかと
間違ってない行為だよと
間違ってない行為は何でしょうかと
怒りに基づいてない行為だよと
怒りに基づいてない行為って何でしょうか
幸せになる行為だよと
幸せになる行為って何でしょうかと言えば
自分のためになる行為
他人のためになる行為
すべての生命のためになる行為が幸せになる行為だよと
それから その行為をすると
どんどん自分の心が善になる
その行為は幸せになる行為ですよと
で 信仰の行為にそれ続けていくんですね
そこでまた王様が キンパナ
これ百十六ページ キンパナバンテヤーナンダソーバガヴァサッベサンゲーバクサラナンダンマーナンウパサンパダンワンネイティ
すべての善を経験すること
体得することをお釈迦様は褒めてますかと
で また同じ答えが出てくるんです
サッバアクサラダンマタヒーノ
お釈迦様だったらすべての不善をなくしているし
すべての善を自分で体得していますよと
そこであの王様が 王様の反応
アッ
チャリヤンバンテアブタンバンテヤワスバシタンチャイダンバンテアヤスマタアーナndeナイミナチャマヤンバンテアヤスマトアーナンダススバシテーナアッタマナ
アビラッハエワンアッタマナアビラッハチャマヤンバンテアヤスマトアーナンダススバシテーナサチェバンテアヤスマトアーナンダスハッティラタナ
カッ
ペイヤハッティラタナピマヤンアヤスマトアーナンダスダデイヤマサチェバンテアヤスマトアーナンダスアッサラタナカッペイヤアッサラタナピマヤンアヤスマトアーナ
ンダスダデイヤマサチェバンテアヤスマトアーナンダスガマワラカッペイヤガマワランティマヤンアヤスマトアーナンダスダデイヤマピチャバンテマヤンティエタンジャ
ナマネタンアヤスマトアーナンダスカッパティティアヤマアヤンメバンテバヒッティコーランニョマーガデーナアジャータサットゥナーヴェーデーヒプッテナ
チャ
ッタナリヤパッキピッタパヒッターソーラサマアーヤメナアッタサマヴィッターレーナサンバンテアヤスマアーナンドパティガンハトゥアヌカンパンウパヤダーヤティア
ランマアーナンダパリプンナムメティチーヴァランティ
まあそこら辺はまあ訳だけでもよろしいと思いますけど
訳で読みましょうか よく解かれたことよ
但し尊者よ 我々は このアーナンダ尊者がよく解かれたことによって喜び満ちております
尊者よ 我々はこのようにアーナンダ尊者がよく解かれたことによって喜び満ちております
尊者よ もしアーナンダ尊者に蔵鋒がふさわしいのであれば
我々はアーナンダ尊者に蔵鋒を施しましょう
尊者よ もしアーナンダ尊者に摩鋒がふさわしいのであれば
我々はアーナンダ尊者に摩鋒をも施しましょう
尊者よ もしアーナンダ尊者に最良の村がふさわしいのであれば
我々はアーナンダ尊者に最良の村をも施しましょう
しかし尊者よ 我々もこれは尊者アーナンダにふさわしくないということを知っております
尊者よ 私にはヴィデーヒー妃の子であるマガダ国王アジャータサットゥから
埠頭 埠頭かな 埠頭に入れて送られた長さ十六に等しい
幅八に等しい gainiがあります
尊者よ アーナンダ尊者は憐れみおされ
それをお受け取りください
大王よ 十分です 私にはサンガは満ちております
それで今王様が自分の悩みが消えちゃったんですね
本当にこの王様がこのいろんな宗教家のいろいろ非難やら褒めやら
そこで困っていたんですね
自分がどんな態度を取るべきかということをね
そこでしっかりとこの道徳論を叩き込まれちゃったんだから
まあこれで自分でしっかりと判断できるんですね
この宗教は恐れると この宗教は怖いとか
そんなことなく 悪いことは悪いやと
いいことはいいやと はっきり言えるこの自信というかね
考え方を自分につけてくれたんですね
思考をしっかりしてくれたんですね
明確に もっといろいろ対話があったでしょうと思いますけどね
それでお坊さんがすごく喜んじゃって
あんたに本当にもうあげたければ何でもあげたい気持ちですよと
でもやっぱりもう比丘だからね
そういうものは受け取ってはいけませんし
とにかく王様がこのものすごい特別に
この隣の国のマガダ国の王様から特別な布を一ついただいたんですね
それものすごい高価なものでしょう
それは王様に特別に何か特別な
あの なんというかね 棺みたいなものに入れて献上されたものなんです
コッサラ王の方がすごい
もっとパワフルなんです
マガダよりも 国も大きいんです
ですから このアジャータサットゥ王っていうのは若いんですからね
またかえって ですから年上の王様にね
それなりに尊敬しないとね
だからそうやって献上したものなんですね
ですから どう見たってもかなりのものだと思います
それでものすごい長いというかね
大きさはちょっとわかりませんですけど
一応まあ一人の人にちゃんと体を巻くぐらいの大きさの
だから衣を作るためだったら結構十分ですね
でもアーナンダ尊者はそれも断るんですね
自分にはちゃんとサンガが今揃ってますと
そこで
アヤンバニ アチラガティナディディッターヤスマターチェヴァアナンデーナアンメーヒチャヤダーウパリパッバテーマハーメーゴーアビッパブットーホーティーアターヤンアチラガティーナジーウブトゥ
ー
kula n
i สังヴィッサンダンティ ガッチャティ エワメワコーバンテヤーヤスマアーナンドー イマーヤ バーヒ
ティカーヤ アッタノーティチーヴァラング カリスサティヤン パナーヤーヤスマトアーナンダッサ プラーナントチーヴァラ
ング タン サッブラフマチャーリーヒ サングビバジッサティ エーヴァヤン アンマカン ダッキーナサングヴィッ
サンダンティ マンニェーガミッサティ パティガンナートゥーバンテヤーヤスマトアーナンドーバーヒティカンティ
どういう意味ですかね
尊者よ このアチラガティ川は山の上で大雨が来るとき
アーナンダ尊者によっても我々によっても見られます
その場合 このアチラガティ川は両岸から溢れて流れます
尊者よ ちょうどそのようにアーナンダ尊者はこの外衣によって自己のサンネを作ることができましょう
また アーナンダ尊者に満ちているサンネは
同行者たちに分配することができましょう
まさにそのように 我々のこの財物は溢れていくであろうと思われます
尊者よ アーナンダ尊者は憐れみよかれ
それをお受け取りください
そこで王様がアーナンダ尊者を説得させるんですね
このアチラガティナディの上の方で雨が降ったら
この川が溢れるということはあなたにも私にも見えるでしょうと
それで そのような感じで
あなたはこの布を持ってサンゲを作って
それでもうあなたそれ着る
あなたのサンゲは他のお坊さんたちに配っちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
衣のないお坊さんたちに
そうするとこの衣の功徳もずっと流れていくんだと
だから王様は一つしかあげませんだけど
それによって布施 布施
布施 布施というふうに順番に流れてるんだって意味なんですね
例えばアーナンダ尊者が上の三枚目の衣がないお坊さんが見つけたら
あるいはもう壊れている
もう破れてるお坊さんが見たら
じゃああんたこれ使ってくださいとあげる
そこでそれは王様のおかげでもらったものだから
王様の布施がそこまで届くと
王様には布施が増えると
そこで着ている衣がないお坊さんにあげたら
そこまた一つとかね そうやって自分の徳がどんどんどんどん川のように流れていくんではないかと
ですからアーナンダ尊者はそれをもらうわけにはいきませんと
と言ったら アーナンダ尊者も王様がどうしてもあげたがってるんだからね
受け取るんですね
パティッガヘーシーコーヤーヤスマアーナンドーバーヒティカンアタコーラージャーパセーナディーコーサローヤーヤスマタンアーナンダンエタジオーチャハンダダ
ーニマヤンバンテーアーナンダガッチャーニバフキッチャーマヤンバフカラニーヤーティヤッサダーニタンマハーラージャカーラムアンニャサーティーティアタコーラ
ージャパセーナディーコーサローヤーヤスマトゥアーナンダッサバーヒタンアビナンダットワアヌモーディットワウッターヤーサナーヤーヤスマタンアーナンダンアビワデ
ィットワパダッキナンカッターパッカーミアタコーヤーヤスマトゥアーヤスマアーナンドーアチラパッカンタッサランニョーパセーナディッサコーサラッサイエーナバグ
ワーティーエナプリサンガムイップラサンカミットワバグワンタンアビワディットワエカマンタンニシディーエカマンタンニシンノーコーアーニシンノーヤーヤスマアー
ナンドーヤーワタコーアホーシランニョーパセーナディーナークーサレーナサッジンカタサッラーポータンサッバンバグワトーアーローチェーシサンチャバーヒタカンバグワトーパーダーシー
で そこまで読んでみましょう
尊者アーナンダは外衣を受けた
さて コーサラ王パセナディは尊者アーナンダにこう言った
それではアーナンダ尊者よ
我々はこれでお暇いたしましょう
我々には仕事も多く しなければならないことがたくさんあります
では 大王よ 清いのままでなさってくださいと
そこでコーサラ国王パセナディは尊者アーナンダが解いたことに歓喜し
喜びを示し 座から立ち上がり
尊者アーナンダを礼拝し
右回りをして去っていった
また去って  さて 尊者アーナンダはコーサラ国王パセナディが去った間もなく
世尊のおられるところに近づいて行った
行って世尊を礼拝し 一方に座った
一方に座った尊者アーナンダはコーサラ国王パセナディと語り合ったことをすべて世尊に報告し
また彼の外衣を世尊に捧げた
アタコーバガワービックーアーマンテーシーラーバハビッキャヴェーランニョーパセーナディッサコーサラッサスラッダラーバハビッキャヴェーランニョーパセーナディ
ッサコーサラッサヤンラージャパセーナディコーサローラバティアーナンダンダッサナーヤラバティパイルーパーサナーヤーティイダマオーチャバガワアッタマナーテービックーバガワトーバーヒタンアビナンドゥンティ
これはお釈迦様のことば
そうして世尊は比丘たちに次のように言われた
比丘たちよ コーサラ国王パセナディには利得があります
比丘たちよ コーサラ国王パセナディには利得がよく得られています
コーサラ国王パセナディはアーナンダに会うことを得
恭しく敬うことを得たのですと
このように世尊は言われた
彼ら比丘は喜び 比丘はですね
比丘たちはですね 世尊が説かれたことに歓喜した
これ教典に記してますけど
お釈迦様がやっぱりあのコーサラ王様もね
あのかなり得をしたんだと
ということは いわゆるアナンダ尊者とね
仲良くできて 仲良く話ができて
大変いいことになりましたという話なんですね
だからまあはっきり言えば
この孝昭王様が結構悩みの多い王様でしたから
そうやって親しく はっきりと教えてくれる人っていうのはかなり凶暴な王なんですよ
それでも だからどんどんどんどんおとなしくなっていったんですね
凶暴な王でしたから 結構もうね
激しい政治活動といろいろやっていたんですね
国も大きいし だから管理も大変でしたし
そこで自分にとっては国が大きい分はかなり精神的な悩みも多かったけど
やっとお釈迦様と仲良くできちゃって
それでお釈迦様にはいつでも会うこともできないし
それでアナンダ尊者やらよく仲良くしていたんですね
彼が王としてはしっかりしていたんだけど
やっぱり個人としてはコソコソコソコソと
お釈迦様やらアナンダ尊者やらそういう人々と個人としてね
仲良くしていて 自分の人生はなんとかうまく政治活動も人間としての生き方もうまくまとめていたんですね
だからそれはこの王にとっては大変な得だよと
お釈迦様も政治的な目で見てるんですよ
この人がこのアナンダ尊者とかね
この付き合いがなかったならば
どうなるかわからない状態なんですね
だから自分は破壊しない
自分は破壊に行かないで済んで幸せになったのは
そういう付き合いがあったんだからなんですね
そこでまあその道徳の論理としても
彼がね すごい悩みがあったし
それでそういう話を聞いてしっかりしたんだからね
それでなんでこの だからこの道徳論聞いたらみんな当たり前のように感じるかもしれない
なんだ当たり前ではそうじゃないんですよ
これ読む時は当たり前に感じるだけで
ブッダの教えっていうのはものすごい超越した教えなんですよ
そこを理解する方法というのは
じゃあ世の中であるすべての道徳論をまとめて読んでみてください
誰かがはっきりと善悪を区別して整理して喋っているかと
西洋にもいっぱいあるでしょうに
倫理学というものは 大学に入って哲学部に入っちゃったら
必ずしも倫理学やらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
いや 誰かがなぜ嘘を言っては悪いか
なぜ殺してはいけないか
なぜ盗んではいけないかと
誰かが世の中の哲学者が一人でもちゃんと整理して語っているかと調べてみてください
それから矛盾ないように
ただ言うのは簡単だからね
嘘を言うなよと それで道徳を語ったことになりません
人を殺すなよと だから例えば聖書にあるようにね
殺すなかれ 終わり それではね
道徳になりませんよ なんで殺してはいけませんか？と言った人が説得力出てこないと
それは世の中でどこにもないんですよ
じゃあ 聖書に証拠を持ってます
聖書がなぜ人殺しはいけないかって
何かありますか？理由でも
旧約聖書でも新約聖書でも殺すなかれとは旧約聖書にもある
新約聖書にもある 十戒の中に
でもあれ なんで悪いんですかね
何もないでしょう 根拠は
神が言ったっていうのだけが基準ですよね
だから神に聞きたいんですよ
言うのは神だからね そういうの全知全能の神だからはっきり言えと
命令だけして握るんだったら私でもできますからね
子供にね しっかり勉強しなさいよって言って
誰にでもできますからね
我々は 子供の場合は勉強しなさいと言ったって
勉強しないってことは知っているし
勉強しない理由も知っているし
それでいろんな試行錯誤というか
ありとあらゆる苦労やら工夫やら手段をとってとって勉強できるようにさせるでしょうに
勉強しろと言うということでは済みませんだから問題は
それが道徳でしょうに
だから我々は現にちょっとした単純な道徳でも
子供に守ってもらうためにどれぐらい苦労しているかというと
それで人殺すなよ そんなことだったら神でなくても
そこら辺にいるヤクザにも言えます
だから偉大なる聖典いろいろいっぱいありますけどね
書いてないんですよ 理由は
わかってない お釈迦様の言葉では
その人々はわかってないんだと
わかるわけもできないんだ
なぜならば 貪瞋痴をなくして心を清らかにするという道がないんだから
真理を百パーセント客観的に見るという方法を持ってないんだから
だから別に非難的にわかってないというわけじゃなくてね
やっぱりまだ勉強していないんだからわかってないんだよと
時々我々同じこと子供に言うでしょうにね
そのうちわかります あれは子供非難してるんじゃないんだからね
まだまだ子供だからね
わからないというぐらいだと
まだまだ頭ができてないんだからね
だからその意味でお釈迦様はみんなわかってないんだと
だから この経典とまたもう一つ
経典いくつかありますけど
同じ問題扱ってるのね
そこら辺でも単純じゃなんだ
これですかと お釈迦様って思っちゃいますけど
そうじゃないんです それは他の人々の教えと比べてみると
だからこの何年前かなね
ある子供がね なぜ人殺すというのは悪いんでしょうかと疑問投げかけたでしょうね
それは日本全国にその子供の疑問が広げたでしょうね
なんであれほどうるさくなったんですかね
日本で一人もいなかったんですよ
人殺しては悪いということは証明できる人が
どうですかね そうすると日本国全国にもいない
ちっちゃな小学生の一人の疑問に答える能力ある？だからそんな簡単なもんじゃないんですよ
日本人も別にね もうそういったもんじゃないでしょうね
それなりにものすごい学問的な能力
知識 ものすごい積み重ねている人々がいっぱいいるという人々を集めて
テレビで相談するわ 喋るわ
喋るわ喋るわ 私も聞いてると
なんだこれ 全然答えが出てこないでしょうと
そこで宗教の方々がこれで慌てていろんな記事が出るわ出るわ出るわ
大風呂敷に回ったんで読んでみたら
もうもう諦めちゃう 飽きちゃうんですね
これぐらいですかと この知識能力は
あの子供に負けてるんではないかと
だから道徳っていうのはそれほど単純じゃないんですよ
そこで私はパティパターでちょこちょこと書きますけど
まとめては書いてないんですけど
そのその日のテーマに合わせますからね
道徳っていうのは 何か何かやるならやるなしなきゃしなきゃいいというのは簡単だよというのはね
それ言っても我々はやっちゃいますよと
嘘をつくなかれと言っても
我々は嘘をついてしまっちゃうんですよ
盗むなかれと言うのは知ってますよ
言われるのは でもやってしまっちゃうんですね
だからそこで理解してほしいのは
人間の衝動なんですよ
人間の衝動が 人を殺したい衝動が本来あろうと
嘘をついたいという衝動が本来あるんですよ
だから いくらうるさく言っても誰も聞いてないんですよ
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
やっぱりこれは人間の本能であって
本能のまんまで生きていると
動物も本能のまんまでしょうに
一度も成長したことがないんですね
だから本能っていうのは
あなたを破壊するためにできているんだと
堕落するためにできているんだと
だからあなたの本当の気持ちは何なのかというと
どんな生命も幸せになりたい
幸福になりたいという気持ちを持っている
希望を持っている 犬も猫も
ミミズさえも アメーバさえも
幸せになりたいんですよ
幸せになりたいのに 生きている衝動がそれを壊すようにできているんです
幸せになれないようにできているんです
ですから 生命が自分の本能で生きていると
生命の目的には達しないんです
逆に行くんです 目的はもう潰れてしまっちゃうんです
ですから 目的は東にあるんだったら
生命が西を向いて歩いているんです
だから東を向いて歩かなくちゃいけない
ただそれだけなんです
それが道徳なんです ですから道徳は絶対的で
もう異論は成り立たないんです
そこでなぜ人を殺すかというと
怒りでしょうね 嫌なものを潰しちゃうんだよと
そうすると 自分も誰かの嫌な嫌なものになってしまえば
その人に私を潰す権利があるんでしょうね
それで生きる目的に達しているんですかね
幸せになりたい 幸福になりたいと
楽に生きていきたいんだということに達してないんですよ
だから殺すなかれという戒律は
動物の世界にも当てはめるんですよ
猿の群れでね みんな楽で楽いたいんだけど
それで自分が強くなりたくてケンカする
ケンカすると自分が不幸になるでしょうに
怪我しちゃうと もう化膿してそれで死んでしまっちゃうでしょうに
だから結局は自分の幸せというのは成り立たなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことで だから殺すなかれ
盗むなかれってのは動物の世界でも同じことで
盗んじゃうと大変なことになるんですよ
動物の世界では まあそれぞれの動物の種類によって
まあいろいろ性格いろいろありますけど
一般的にはやっぱり大変なことになります
ですから生命の心っていうのは貪瞋痴という衝動で活動するようにできていて
でも気持ちは幸せになりたいと
希望は で どうも残念なことに
貪瞋痴でいっちゃうと幸せになれないということには気がつかないんです
それで幸せだと勘違いしている
それでみんな欲のままで生きていて
好きなものばっかり揃ってもらって
幸せになるどころか もっと苦しみが増えるだけで
だから国が豊かになればなるほど問題は大きくなる
危険性が高くなるとかね
我々の家は豊かになればなるほど泥棒に入られる
もう危険性が増えるとかね
首にダイヤのネックレスなんか着けちゃうと殺される可能性はものすごく高くなる
一人で歩けなくなっちゃうっていうんです
確かにダイヤのネックレスは高価なものかもしれませんだけどね
それでただそれ好き それだけのことね
それでじゃあ買っちゃったと
じゃあ買ったものだから
せっかく買ったものだから
じゃあ着けて歩こうと歩いたところで殺されちゃうんですからね
ですから 人間が欲のままで生きていると
自分の危険というものはどんどん大きくなっていく
それで何が失うかというと
幸せを失うんですよ なんでダイヤのネックレス買ったかというと
幸せになるためなんですね
それで何が失ったかというと
幸せなんです ですから
自分の家で駐車場あるんだとします
駐車場もあることで 車でも買いましょうと行って調べたらお金がない
それちょうどあの時が使ってないんだからね
あれ売っちゃえば車買えますよと
言って駐車場売っちゃう
売っちゃったところで車を買うお金が入るんです
かえって車買っちゃうと駐車場
だからそれでどうしますかね
ん？だから我々の生き方はそういう生き方なんですね
ネックレスが欲しいと
それやったら私は幸せだわと思って買うでしょうし
それで自分の命も亡くなるという危険性もついてくるということなんですね
それで気楽に生きるということは
その瞬間から消えちゃうんですよ
昔のエピソードがありまして
あの ある王様がいて あの
まあ夜 なかなか寝られない時とかね
夜寝れないし 窓のところで座ってるんです
宮殿だから大きいんだからね
と なんかすごい歌声聞こえるんですね
誰かがヴィーナを弾いて
ヴィーナ昔インドのヴィーナっていうんだかバイオリンのかどうですけどもね
あまりにも綺麗なんですね
そこでその歌も何の悩みもない
何の苦しみもない ただその本人が自分が今日は一日良かったという感情を歌ってるんですね
自分の宮殿ではそういう歌声は聞こえないんです
みんな仕事で給料で歌ってるんだから
王様があまりにも感動して
何でしょうかね あの人はと
誰ですかと調べた 調べたらホームレスの一人なんです
その人はあちこち歩いて
何か誰か誰かだから ちょっとご飯もらって
こじきせて食べて まあまあ
別に日本みたいに寒いってわけでもないんだから
そこら辺どこかに横になって寝てもう楽しいんですね
まあせっかく楽しいんだから
一つ一曲でも歌おうと
そこで自分のあのプロ
何と言いますか 相談するこの頭のいいブラミン人たちがいるんだから
その自分の一番目の相談役の人を呼んでね
賢者を呼んでその話をしたんですね
なんであの人は何もないのに
あれほど生きる喜びを感じているんですかと
このこの国で全て持っている私には生きる喜びを感じないんだと
夜も寝られないんだと
言ったらその人が理由はそれですよと
このいろんなものがあることだよと
そんなはずがないでしょう
いくらでも何かお金やらいろいろあった方が人はより幸せではないかと
私はその人にも綺麗な服を着てね
家があって 何かあったらすごく幸せにいるだろうと
もっとすごい歌を歌うだろうと思いますと
と思うんですよ 言ったらこの賢者の人がじゃあ分かりました
王様がその人に川柳をあげてくださいと
金貨のね じゃあ川柳をあげたら
その人は一生贅沢に生きられると
たら 何のことなく王様のところから川柳の袋をすくって
家来の人がそそそそって
これはもうあなたにあげるよと王様が言いましたから
もらいなさいと 王様の命令ですよと
その人はこじきですよ
笑っちゃったんですね
その日から歌声消えちゃったんです
彼が夜も寝られなくて
殺してこれ持っていったらどうしますかと
そこで何日間経ってから
その人がもう王様の宮殿の前で必死になってお願いするんです
どうかそれ戻して返しますよ
もらってくださいと 許してくださいと
お返しよと 私は幸せに生きていたいんだと
王様もやっと目が覚めたんだと
やっぱり幸せっていうのはそういう貪瞋痴の世界にあるものじゃないんだと
それは仏典に入ってくるエピソードなんですけどね
だから生きていきたい我々はお金のために人を殺すなりする
それで生きていきたいというその目的も消えてしまう
だから 人間の心の構成って
人間だけではなく どんな生命にも心の構成っていうのは幸せになりたいという希望がある
それを達する道がわからない
幸せを壊す道がわかる
だから結果としては残るのは苦しみでしょ
希望は叶ってないんだから
それでなんで人間がまたお釈迦様が考えるなんで人間がそんなに幸せになれないんですかというと
生きること自体が苦しいんだからなんです
それでなんでこの苦しみが生まれてくるんですか？と
それも勉強します それも貪瞋痴なんですね
ですから 貪瞋痴だけは毒であると
三毒ですと それを消せと
その消す生き方は道徳なんですよ
それは徹底した科学的な教えであって
何も異論なり立たないんです
ですから この道徳っていうのは一旦理解したら
もう絶対的に守るもんなんですよ
で なんで人類が道徳を守ってないかというと
もう誰にも教えてないんだからなんです
それで仏典ではそこら辺を明確に道徳セットっていうのをきちんと整理して証拠を出してできているんです
だから王様にこの王様にしたっても
どうしようかな もういろいろもう宗教というのは神秘ばっかりでしょうね
宗教家侮辱しちゃったら罰が当たるかもしれませんとかね
あの人すごい山に入っていろんな行をやっているんだから
いろいろ超能力・神通力持っているかもしれません
それで王様に呪いかけちゃうかもしれませんとかね
そういういろいろ迷信的な不満もあるでしょうね
だから王様がもうみんな根拠ないところでいろいろ批判するし
私ら困りますよと 根拠あって批判するんだったら
私もなんとかしてあげることできますけどと
というと 悩んでいるところで
アナンダ尊者がしっかりとこれが真理だよと
これが道徳ですよと そちらの宗教っていうのは入ってないんです
仏教の道徳には 信仰・宗教ってのは入ってない
単なる真理 それで王様はしっかりします
よし 分かりましたと これでもう誰の間違いでも正せるんだよということなんですね
ですから この読めれば読んだところで簡単にわかるということで
お釈迦様の智慧がほんのちょっとと思ったら
そこはすごく違うんです
これもお釈迦様の智慧なんですよ
これほど難しい真理を子供にしてもなんとか分かりますよ
そうやって誰にでも理解できるように語るということも
ブッダ以外誰にもできないんです
だから このちょっと読みにくい
このいろいろ校注とかいろいろあるんだけど
それはもうしょうがないんです
それで簡単にわかるんです
だから 文句とかね あることで忘れられなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば嘘をついてはいけないとって言っちゃうと
なぜいけないというと
まず嘘をついて何するかというと
人を騙すんですね 自分の利益のために
一番目は自分を騙して自分の財産を奪うことは自分が好きですか？好きじゃない
でも私は人を騙しますよと
というと じゃああなたはあなたを騙すことを認めますかと
どうか私も騙してくださいと
私は訴えませんと そう認めてないでしょうに
自分が人に嘘をついてその人を騙す
でも人が自分を騙したと分かったら訴えちゃうんですね
騙されたと おかしいでしょうね
それだったら それから逆にみんな嘘だけ言ってるんだったら生きていられますかね
お母さんの話も信じられないし
お父さんの話も信じられないし
先生の誰の話も信じられなくなるでしょうに
嘘言うことになっちゃうと
だから我々は幸せに生きているのは
それなりにみんな事実を語っているんだからなんです
それなりに ですから この世の中いくらかでもうまくいっているのは事実を語る分だけなんですよ
我々はすごく困っているのは
みんな嘘を言っているところなんですね
政治家から財界の大物やら家の夫婦の間やら
子供と両親の間やら トラブルを起こすのはいつでも嘘をつく分ですよ
お互いに信頼し合ってしっかり生きていられるのは真実を語るもんなんですよ
ですから 幸せに生きたければ
面倒くさいことを嫌であるならば
嘘を言ってはいけないんです
ただそれ単純なことなんです
それは神が言ったんだからしたっていい加減にしなさいと
だから仏教の道徳っていうのは
神が言っても言わなくても
ブッダが言っても言わなくても
これは誰とも関係あるものじゃない
あなたのことだと だから私たちの場合は
私が嘘をつきませんという立場であって
ブッダに見せる顔がないんだから嘘をつきませんという立場じゃないんです
私が言いません なぜかというと
私がそれでもう不幸になるものだからと
いろんなトラブルを起こしちゃいますから
それで私が相手を裏切ってない場合は
相手が私を裏切ったら私には訴える権利あるでしょうに
ですから 事実を語る人にとっては騙されるということは成り立たないんです
どうせ自分が正直で事実を語る人だったら
みんなあの人にはそんなこと言わなくたっても
ただ淡々と事実だけ言っちゃえばもうやってくれますよってことになるんですよ
だから私も嘘を言うんだから
相手方もいろいろいろいろ嘘をつくんですよ
それでややこしい世界観が生まれてきて
犯罪まで起きてきて 生きることは苦痛になってしまっちゃうんですね
だからそういうことだから
幸せで幸福で生きる生きるためにための生き方が道徳であって
あれはいろいろ人々が言っているものは道徳ではありません
だから神が言ったんだから
人を殺せない人が道徳の人ではありません
なしなれば もしあの神様が心臓発作でも起こして死んじゃったならば
その人は人を殺すんだから
神様もずいぶんわがまま好き勝手でしょうに
例えば ある日突然気が変わっちゃって
もう何か違うことを言ったならば
私はあなた方をもう救うことをやめますよと
もう天国は満員ですよと
という例えば予言があったならば
新しいモーセスが現れてきて
そのモーセスに神がそう言ったならば
今まで人を殺さないでいる人々も人を殺したということでなるでしょうね
だから誰かに言われる言われているんだからとやるものは単なる脅しであって
腰抜けですよ それは道徳にならない
腰抜けだからやってないだけ
例えば警備員がいるんだから万引きしないというならば
それはもう道徳とは思わません
店で警備員がいるところが
店の人も家の中に入っちゃって
台所へなんかこそこそとやっている
それでも来た子供がもうおばあちゃん
おばあちゃんと叫んで叫んで
これちょうだいというならば
それが道徳を守っているんですよ
おばあちゃんないんだから持って行けと言っちゃうと
そこは道徳じゃないでしょうに
だから自分が守るということが道徳なんです
仏教の修行する人々が脅しても破らないんだと
普通の人は脅されちゃうと破っちゃいますけどもね
これやらなかったら殺すぞと言ったら
やっぱり命可愛いんだからやりますよ
仏教の世界ではそれでもやらないという
もう道徳に対してはもうしっかりしているんです
なぜかで それはもうお釈迦様おっしゃったんだからと
そんな見栄ではないんです
仏教徒だからとか 何何からと言ったら道徳ではありません
親に散々言われたんだからね
私 キリスト教やめているんだよと言ったら
もう道徳じゃないんですよ
本人が理解しなくてはいけない
これ私の道だと だから道徳には見張り番は要りません
それからそれで仏教では善因善果でしたっけ？悪因悪果という
もう成り立ってますから
悪いことしたら自分でまいた種自分であるんだから
それを理解すると 自分でちゃんと正しいで生きていられるんですよ
だからあの小学生でもね
もう誰かいたら その子にじゃああなたを殺したらどうですか？質問出したらどうですか？と
言ったら やっぱり誰かその質問出されたみたいですね
言ったら別にどうったことないんだと
だったら自分が人を殺しても何か悪いと思っているんだから
もう自分が殺されたら別にどうったこと思わないんだと
それで手分けでしょうに
そんな単純じゃないんです
あの子供の質問は だから私がだったら
じゃああなたが自分を殺したらどう思います？と言ったら
その子はそう言うかもしれません
私はいきなりこう言うんです
あんた嘘をついてるんだよと
あんたこの世の中では一番嘘つきやと
子供は怒るんですね 自分が嘘つきだと言われたら
怒ってもらって なぜならば
あなた自分の命はね 殺されたっていうのはいいと思うならば
なんで君がそんな服着ているんですか？なんで君がそんな一生懸命美味しいご飯とか
お母さんに文句言いながらね
あれ食べたくない これ食べたいとかくちゃくちゃ食べてるんですか？とかね
あんた生きてるでしょうにと
あんた生きてきたっても何の意味もないんだと
あんた今の瞬間に死ぬんだよと
あんた 1分でだけでも頑張って生きているということは
あんた生きていきたいんだからですよと
それは認めない あなたは世の中では一番最低の嘘つきやと
だから嘘つきにはもう人殺してはいけないかと
そんなのわかるわけないんだよと
だからあの子はまあそういう状態なんですよ
本当はそうでもなくて
ただ大人からかっただけだと思いますけどね
大人はバカやってことに気づいちゃってね
みんなただオウム返ししてるだけで
誰も真剣真面目じゃないんだと
言って子供は自分の存在についてすごい不安を感じたと思いますよ
こんな大人言うこと聞いて大丈夫かと
みんないい加減ではないかと
我々のこと本当に心配しているんじゃないでしょうと
みんな親からみんなオウム返しばっかりやってるんではないかと
子供は時々そういうことをすごく厳しく感じるんですよ
本気で自分を愛しているかということ
だから仏教はすべての生命を本気で慈しみでみなさいと言ってるんだからね
この子はそれに気づいちゃったんですよ
でも治す方法はいろいろあるんです
答えもいろいろあるんです
ただ 一つの論理は あなたは 1分でも生きていることはおかしいんだと
だって殺す権利があるんだったら
殺される権利がある いわゆる殺す
殺すことは嫌じゃないってことでしょ
だったら早く死ねよと
いろいろね 綺麗な服を着たり
かっこいいいろんなものを体につけたり
いろんなことをしないで早く死ねよと
今すぐ それはやらんでしょう
だから結局は死にたくないだけだと
あんたは死にたくない
あなたを誰が生かしてるんでしょうかと
世界はあなたを生かしてるんだよと
だから裏切るなよと 世界を
ご飯を持ってくるお母さんの手を噛むなよと
手を噛んじゃったら お母さんがのご飯の皿を落としちゃいますよ
そうするとあんたに食べられないんだと
それの逆にお母さん本当に毎日ありがとうございますと言ってみなさいよと
お母さん もっとより美味しいご飯作ります
それが普通の常識的な生き方だよと教えてあげられるんですよ
その単純なことは誰にも頭に浮かばないということを
私に浮かぶのはお釈迦様のおかげですけどね
それがあの子に出すべき答えでしたけどね
でもかなりにものすごい放送時間も使ってディスカッションするわするわするわ
一人にも答えがない 今の少年たちのいろいろ精神的な問題についてとかね
みんな喋って忘れる 喋って忘れる
ただ ワイドショーにも2
3時間時間取っていただければ
それで食べて終わると
誰一人答え出せない やはりその頭の悪さっていうのは
ブッダの智慧でないと解決しないと思います
なぜかというと 貪瞋痴でない世界を語っているのは
世の中でブッダだけなんですよ
美しい言葉はほとんどみんな語ってます
西洋哲学者でもね かなりすごい立派な美しい言葉っていうのを語っていることは確かに語ってます
でも貪瞋痴は良くないというと
そこが基本的な問題だよということは発見したのはブッダだけなんですね
ですからまあ 誰でもやっぱりいくらかな欲ではいいやっていうところでいるんだからね
あるインターネットである人と会話したことが昔あったんで
それは面倒くさいからそのプログラムを随分昔に消してしまっちゃったんです
今も登録はありますけど
プログラムは動かないようにしているんです
誰か知らない人なんです
いきなり話しかけてきて
言葉の使い方とか そのやり方からもおそらくアメリカだろうと思いますけどね
それは道徳的な話なんですね
神の話やら色々 それに一応返事を出す出す出すても
私はもう一つ仕事があったんで
その人からもう話しかけてきちゃうとね
その場で答えなくちゃあかんでしょうしね
向こうは待ってるんだから
時計見ちゃったら もうこちらは真夜中で
向こうはおそらくもう昼でしょうしね
もう気楽にやってるところだから
で このLOVEというね
言葉についても彼がいろいろ意見聞くんですね
で 彼が一つもう出しちゃったんで
自分がキリスト教の当たり前でね
そこら辺からいろいろ話を出して
やっぱりこの優しい良い人には
優しくするのはそれは私はすごく正しいと思ってます
でも世の中で悪い人間としてはやっぱり厳しくするべきですよと
ですからLOVEはいいことですけど HATE
ということもとることも必要ですよと You
have to hate evilと書くんですね
私がI don't find any reason to hate anybodyと答えたかったんですね
私は誰にでも憎しみの理由はわかりませんと
それで彼がもういろいろ人を殺したり
いろんな国際的ないろんなものとか出して
そういう場合はね あんた放っておけというんですかと
イランのもうなんとか人とかね
それは外国で じゃあその人のことを恨んで
あんたは何をするんですかと
じゃあフセインをYou canYou can hate as you as much as you like Mr.フセイン And
what will happen to him and all to you？って私は聞いた
あなたとあなたに何がなるんですか？と
フセインに何がなるんですか？答えはフセインは全然そんなこと関係ない
フセインを恨んでいる本人が苦しむだけですと
そういう部分を本人にはものすごくきつく聞くんですよ
とにかく それで私はもう会話をやめたくてね
こう言ったんですよ あなた方の宗教でどう言おうとも
それは私に関係ないんですよと
それから私が言うのは優しい
私はこちらの言う言葉が良かったんですよ
優しい人に優しくすることは動物にもできますよと
犬にも猫にもできますよと
そのまま英語で書いたんです
犬にも猫にも 誰にでも親切な人には親切にすることができるですよと
それが人間も同じことをやって立派だと威張るのはちょっとおかしいんだと
一番難しいことは 優しくない乱暴な人に愛することやと
それが道徳だと私は思いますよと
それによって我々は精神的に優れた人間になるんだよと
ですから私はその道だから
いかなる理由があっても他人を卑ってから憎しむことは私は認めませんと
ただ彼があなたのおっしゃるとおりですよと言って話を処理したんです
負けちゃって完全に ですから
この やっぱり完璧に喋ってないんで喋られてない
そういう人々に だからみんな心の中であり
それでも葛藤とかね いろいろ曖昧なところがあって
そこは自由自在に自分の感情で解説すると
それでまた問題が起きる
ですから この曖昧で批判できる
反論できる道徳っていうのは道徳ではないんです
人が怖いんだから守る道徳も道徳じゃないんです
絶対的なものだけ道徳なんです
私を殺してもやりませんと
あなたに脅された 脅されたんだからといって
私は私のポリシーを変えませんよという
それが道徳なんです ですから
そういうしっかりした論理的な道徳がお釈迦様はすごくわかりやすく語ってます
お釈迦様がすごい教えがあるんだから
子供読んだってわかる
だから子供に嘘をつくなよではなくて
君が君にとって嫌なことはやめなさいよとかね
お父さんからお母さん
みんな嫌がることをやめなさいよとかね
みんなに嫌われることをやめた方がどうでしょうか
それだけでしょう そうすると君はすごく可愛いとみんな思いますよと
それが道徳なんですよ
それが哲学者にでも理解できないところなんです
ですから 私は昔ね かなり昔なんですけど
これ子供とこれちょっと確かめてみたんですよ
やっぱりいいこと言うことを聞いてくれない
ちょっと激しい 乱暴なね
精神的にちょっとヒステリックなこのハイポテンションの子供たち出てきますからね
そのハイポテンションになっちゃうとどうも手に負えないんですよ
で 私はそういう子一人二人捕まっちゃって
まずこのハイポテンション直りませんだからね
まずものすごい愛情をあげたんですね
だからみんなに嫌われている
私はもうこそこそと自分のところに呼んでもらってね
ものすごくもう仲良くしてたんですね
子供にまずそれ理解できない
なんでみんな私のことを悪く悪口ばっかり
お母さんは私のことを怒りっぱなしなのに
こんなにも愛情ですかと
単純に私はね 二人で友達になろうよと言ったんですよ
子供にとって友達になるということはすごく大事な言葉なんですよ
そこでいいよと それでまあ友達になって
それで二人でこの道徳と何とか
ことはなくてね ただふだり友達だから
年はものすごい違いますけどね
いろいろいろいろ喋ってるんですよ
それでなんであのある日
切さん そうね なんでこのなんとか人からこう言われちゃったんだけど
あんたはね もう目の前でいたんですよ
こいつはね お坊さんも動物を見ただけでも石を投げて殺しちゃいますよ
あっちこっちスリランカでは野生の動物いっぱいいますから
小さなリスやらいっぱい
誰にも何も害を与えませんね
みんな怒るんですよ 鳥にでも石を投げちゃうと投げちゃうと
カラスにでも石を持って投げちゃうと
何やってるんですか？そういうことだから
その子は投げちゃうんですね
そこで言ったら 私でも二人間でいるところで言って
その人いたんですね 言って
私はその子 本当そんなことやってるんで怒らなかったんです
友達だから怒らないでしょう
私は なんででしょうね
ああいうことになるのは
けど その子もね そうですね
本当はね このリスなんか見ると
なんか居られなくなっちゃうんだから
私は なんか捕まりたくなっちゃって
いられなくなっちゃうんだと
それで石を石で投げちゃいますけど
これ悪いことにちょうど当たるんだと
これ悪いことにぴったし体に当たるじゃん
で リスが死んじゃう だからかえって考えちゃうと
子供は別に殺してやるという気持ちあるわけじゃないし
単なる子供にある興味と苛立ちだけのことなんですね
だから私が考える自分もそういう子供頃あったんだから
動物見ちゃうとなんとか捕まりたくなるんですよ
それでどんどんいろいろお話を聞いて
それから もう何一つ悪いことをしない子供になっちゃったんですね
何かしたって言ったら
私は私はちょっと一言
私はあなたのことを本当に信頼していたんですけど
言った途端 隠してた悪いことでも全部言う
あれはあれが私がやったんだよと
そうじゃあまあ気をつけてね
それで終わっちゃうんですね
すごいみるみるうちにものすごい立派な子になっちゃって
それでも半年かな もうものすごいみんなにもいい子いい子だとね
みんなに可愛がるようになってしまったんですね
そのどころか 他の子供たちがなんかいたずらしちゃうと
こいつは言って もう脅して何やってるんだと
そこまでやめてくれと
だからきちんと理解できるようにしてあげると
自然に道徳の人間になるんです
私は鳥一番の昔 子供の頃捕ろうと思ったら
いろいろ罠を仕掛けたりして頑張ってるんですね
まあ下手くそな罠ですけどね
鳥なんかそんな風に捕まれませんし
で まあ母親ちらっとそれ見たんですね
そしたらやめなさいとか何やってるの？って何も言わなかったんです
言って それ罠をかけて竿も入れて
鳥が来るまで待っていなくちゃいけないんだから
その間でちょっと台所の方行ったんですね
母がもう台所何かやりながらね
あのね 誰か君に罠かけて捕まって持っていったら
君どうしますかねと ちょっとそれだけ
誰かが来て 君に罠かけて
足に引っ張って連れて行っちゃったら
君どうしますかねと そう言われた瞬間で
あ これが悪いと と言って
逆に鳥のお母さんどう思いますかね？子供を捕まったと岩田をそれ一言も付けられたんです
ただそれだけで 私にとってはすごくこのピッチャー絵をね
頭に来るんです 自分を捕まれて
誰かにお母さんに会えなくなっちゃってというと
自分がどれほど悲しいかと
いうと あの鳥のお母さんもやっぱり子供捕まったらやっぱりどうにもならなくなるでしょうとね
それで終わり もう何のこともなく
動物をいじめたこともないし
別にそれでもって威張ったことでもないし
ただ何かいじめる気持ちにはならないだけ
ただ 動物の痛みはすぐ感じちゃうっていうかね
ですから道徳っていうのは
それは私は地獄に落ちるんだからっていうことまるっきりないし
動物いじめなかったら天国に行けるんだからっていう話もないし
あんたは動物いじめないんだから立派な子ですよという母に褒められてもらうことも絶対なかったし
何もない でもやらないだけ
で 他人にもやらせることは絶対不可能だと思います
私の生き方をめぐようと思っても
この人類にできないと思いますよ
でも私はやってないいいことを論理的に言えばやってもらうことはできます
それでも屁理屈で言っちゃうと
すぐ潰しちゃう 根本的にあんたはこういうことなのにやってないでしょ？って言ったら
あ そうだ すぐ分かってそれやりますけど
逆にやってない悪いことを何かしらやってもらいたくて
いろいろ誘惑される それは絶対無理だと思います
もし私が悪いことをやるんだったら
私の意思でやるんです
自分の責任で あの人に言われたんだからとか
そんなもう情けないことはしません
私がやったよと 何をと
という立場取るんです
そういうことだからね
やっぱりこの道徳論というのはものすごい大事なことで
我々のもう生き方 全て人類の平和
幸せ 全て決めるものなんですよ
それがものすごい教育よりも何よりも大事なんですよ
学校で勉強するものは
どこかに会社で歳まで仕事をするためだけでしょうに
会社退職したら勉強したものは何の役にも立たんでしょうに
どんなエンジニアになっちゃっても
会社終わっちゃったらそこで植木鉢をいじるだけの人生でしょうに
だから生まれた瞬間から死ぬ瞬間まで
どのように生きているかということが一生の財産であります
ですから 一番厳密に子供たちに最初に教えて納得させて置いておかなくちゃいけないということは
自分の足で歩けという一言葉なんです
自分のことには自分で責任持ちなさいよと
子供にはやっぱりこの項目いうことはよくないと思いますけどね
道徳項目 まあこちらでもお釈迦様は道徳項目は言わないんですね
この幸せの道を教える
それが道徳になる そういうことだから
このすごい単純な教典なんですけど
それぐらいその裏にお釈迦様の智慧もあります
話はそこら辺で終了します
どうもありがとうございます